every time i fly into kansas city to
give a speech there's a problem a few
years ago i flew in to speak at the
university of missouri kansas city to
give a speech titled men are not women
and some wacko in the audience attacked
me and the following day the chancellor
of the university sent out an email to
the entire school
apologizing
not to me for being attacked but to
everyone else for the fact that i had
been invited in the first place
well it's deja vu all over again
this thursday i am scheduled to fly into
kansas city to give another speech
this time at washburn university in
topeka the student group that invited me
wants me to speak on the very same topic
this confusion between men and women and
what the difference is it seems to have
only gotten worse in recent years as
judge katanji jackson proved last week
during her supreme court nomination or
her confirmation hearings rather when
she could not define the word woman
yet again
the university leadership has sent out
an email
condemning me
for a speech i have not yet given
for making the bold and controversial
claim
that boys and girls are different
i received an anonymous tip last night
that has since been confirmed
that the president of the university
jerry farley
sent out a campus-wide email
preemptively condemning me for the
speech that i have yet to give
this president jerry farley i've just
confirmed with young america's
foundation
personally signed the contract inviting
me to speak he personally signed a
physical contract on march 8th saying
michael please come visit washburn
university and give your talk and now
before i even give this speech this man
is condemning me as the worst person in
the world here's what he had to say to
the washburn university community a
washburn student organization has
invited a speaker to campus who has a
history of inciting fear and distrust
while i am strongly in support of first
amendment rights i am disappointed when
those rights are used to make others
feel unwelcome and even unsafe in our
community while we support the right to
speak freely washburn university does
not condone the hate and misinformation
spread by the speaker and his supporters
i'm going to pause right there those are
some pretty bold claims
that this man is making about me
inciting fear and distrust
making others feel
unsafe spreading hate
and misinformation
what evidence does he cite for for these
defamatory claims
nothing of course
no evidence exists it's just not true
i haven't done any of those things he is
libeling and defaming me
a speaker who he personally invited to
his campus when he signed that contract
there's a personal invitation he is
endorsing the student group's invitation
he is he is defaming me in the most
vicious language he can based on
absolutely nothing
he goes on
thursday also happens to be
international trans visibility day
washburn university supports the trans
community and students who identify as
lgbtq plus
side note apparently now we're
capitalizing the t in trans i don't know
when that happened that's the new thing
so just to let you know where the rules
are
transvisibility day by some happy
coincidence or
providence perhaps he goes on
we support and stand in solidarity with
trans people around the world and
encourage you to learn more about the
issues affecting students
faculty and staff who identify as lgbtq
plus
we will continue to engage our resources
to influence the campus community
to be an inclusive place where all feel
they are protected
affirmed
and valued
an inclusive place
where everyone is affirmed and valued
except for that hate-mongering monster
michael knowles that devil himself who
has the gall to say that boys aren't
girls
at a university
except for the students who invited that
horrible monster and the faculty and
every sensible person in the history of
the world
all of whom know that men and women are
different all of whom said so until five
minutes ago when our leaders decided we
were not allowed to state basic truths
anymore
he concludes i encourage you to
celebrate the day with messages of
compassion and support with your help
this university can be a shining light
and example to the greater community
we will learn together and from each
other and we will be better people for
the effort
jerry farley
president
i hope we will learn together i hope the
excitable leftists at washburn
university president farley foremost
among them will be able to learn from my
speech on thursday about how boys and
girls are different
probably should have learned that a
little bit earlier than college i
probably should have learned that a
little bit earlier than becoming the
president of a college but i hope
they learn basic truths about human
nature and if that's too much for them
i hope at the very least they learn that
conservatives are not going to be
bullied and silenced and forced to
kowtow to their ridiculous ideological
fantasies i'm michael knowles this
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from kenny newdorf
who says i like how people talk about
really accepting who you are while they
are taking medications to change
everything about themselves well this is
just the point isn't it we're told you
have to accept who you really really are
deep deep down and to who you really
really are according to this
destructive ideology
has absolutely nothing to do with the
person that you are in reality it's who
you really really are is
according to these people
what you are in secret
has nothing to do with the physical
world has nothing to do with what we can
see and touch and feel and no it has
nothing to do with that
it's something completely different and
so accepting who you are means
mutilating your body taking all sorts of
drugs and trying to deny
who you really are not a great idea
you want to be in this life you want to
be the best version of yourself who you
really truly are not some fantasy but
who you really truly are you want your
car and your truck to be the best
version of themselves which is why
you've got to check out
rockauto.com right now go to
rockauto.com and write knowles
k-n-o-w-l-e-s
in there how did you hear about xbox so
they know that i sent you
rockauto.com is going to save you money
it's going to save you time it's going
to help you to
improve your car improve your truck to
do the things that you've got to do to
get around to live your life and you're
not going to have to stand and wait at
the brick and mortar store where you
drive you wait in line you get peppered
with a thousand questions they don't
have the part because there's just too
many parts to stock these days then you
got to go back you got to wait two weeks
don't do it rockauto.com
same reliably low prices for pros and
do-it-yourselfers
you could save 20 30 50
on the parts that you need the website's
so easy to navigate even i can do it
there are great family company serving
auto parts customers online for 20 years
great supporters of this show which we
really appreciate head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your cart or truck and
then write knowles k o w l e s and their
how did you hear about this box so they
know that we sent you
the transgenderism issue
is such a big national debate
not because the majority of people are
confused about the difference between
men and women
they're not
the vast majority of people
are extremely clear on the difference
between boys and girls
it reminds me of that meme the iq bell
curve meme where you've got the really
dumb person all the way at the bottom of
the bell curve and he says you know
men and women are different
and then you go all the way to the top
of that bell curve at the iq i don't
know about 110 iq 120 iq so you've got
some genius ices actually men and women
are exactly the same and actually men
can become women and actually it has
nothing to do and i can't define what a
woman is i'm not a biologist and then
all these kind of and then you get all
the way to the top of the iq bell curve
and you get the super duper genius jedi
and he says
actually men and women are different
roger scrutin the late conservative
philosopher he said the job of the
conservative intellectual is to
articulate
the things that the common people know
to be true intuitively
that's the job
and it's only those people in the middle
who seem to get very very confused about
this sort of thing
the vast majority of people
know that this ideology that is now
pumping little kids full of cross-sex
hormones that is mutilating people's
perfectly healthy organs they know that
the ideology is wrong it's based on
fantasy and it's extremely destructive
so then why are we still talking about
it why does this ideology keep getting
pushed because it is an elite issue the
elites in government in academia in
corporate america the elites are
disproportionately pushing this issue
i'm not sure that there's any study on
this so i'm not studying statistics i'm
just speaking anecdotally
in my experience
the people who identify as transgender
disproportionately come from the elite
classes come from very wealthy people
with
with fathers and mothers usually who are
working at very elite jobs that tends to
be where this kind of sexual confusion
lies in my experience and this was just
a
bolster this thesis was just bolstered
by a ceo or the corporate president
rather at disney
christopher ruffa who's done a great job
exposing critical race theory in schools
is over at the manhattan institute
chris ruffo has just come upon
some private footage of an all hands
call at disney a video call where the
disney corporate president
described her multiple trans and
pansexual children and called for more
lgbtq leads in disney movies
i'm here as a mother of two queer
children actually
one transgender child
um and one pansexual child um
and and also as a leader
um and that was the thing that really
got me because i have heard so much from
so many of my colleagues over the course
of the last couple weeks
um in open forums and through emails and
phone conversations and
um i feel a responsibility to speak um
not just for myself but for them
to all of us we had a we had an open
forum last week at 20th where
um
again the home of of really incredible
groundbreaking
lgbtqia stories over the years where
um one of our execs stood up and said
you know we only have a handful of queer
leads
in our content and i went what
that can't be true and i and i and i
realized oh it actually is true we have
many many many lgbtqia characters
in our stories and
and and yet we don't have enough
leads
an issue a sexual and ideological issue
that affects
an extraordinarily small percentage of
the population that is represented in an
extraordinary large proportion of the
media and in the classrooms and in the
corporate boardrooms the problem we are
told is that
it's not represented enough
trans visibility day where we need
transvisibility day
the issue's visible folks the issue is
visible the elites in every sphere of
our society are pushing it they're
shouting it from the rooftops
now speaking of shout i would strongly
recommend you check out shout out have
you ever wanted to send your
conservative uncle a birthday greeting
from one of his favorite conservative
celebrities
have you ever wanted to send your
liberal cousin a birthday greeting from
one of her least favorite conservative
celebrities have you ever wanted to do
that well there's only one place to do
it and that would be shout out that is
the shout out app the most popular
personalities on the right are all there
they're ready to make someone's day with
a personalized video how do you do it
you download shout out now on the app
store or google play and you will get
twenty percent off your first customized
shout out video from the likes of oh i
don't know steven crowder ever you hear
over here about that guy the hodge twins
jp sears jason whitlock or alex jones i
want one from alex jones michael happy
birthday don't drink the water i know
i'm starting to believe that about the
water right now head on over to shout
out download the app from
the apple app store from google play get
it and make your conservative uncle's
day or ruin your liberal cousin's day
shout out on the app store the corporate
president of disney
says that it's very important that we
have not just more lgbt lmnop characters
in our movies there are already a lot
but we need more lgbt lmnop
leads
there are actually already a lot but we
need more and she says this because
she's the parent she's the mother
of
a transsexual child
and a pansexual child
now
she's not she's not the mother of a
transsexual and a pansexual
she i'm sure is the mother of these two
children
and i have no doubt that these children
are confused i don't i don't doubt her
that they have sexual confusion but she
is not the mother of a transsexual and a
pansexual because those are not real
categories of being
i'm not denying anybody's existence
i'm not saying that anyone is invisible
to use the language that is so popular
these days on the left
but the people that we're talking about
here are not transsexual or pansexual as
the newest i don't know what i think
pansexual is just a high-class version
of bisexual i don't exactly know what
even the meaning the purported meaning
of pansexual is but whatever it is
these people are not that because it's
not a real category of being because a
man cannot secretly be a woman it's just
not possible lump that one away with
bigfoot and the boogeyman it's not real
the
confusion that these people have may be
real
a psychological problem
that they have might be real or a social
problem which seems to be the case as
these minor minor relatively
small issues in terms of the population
have now exploded to a huge proportion
of gen z in particular so it might be
the social problem might be real the
confusion might be real but the actual
condition
is not because it's it is not possible
i i
i repeat it because we seem to be so
confused it is not possible for a man to
secretly be a woman or for a man to
become a woman or for a man to change
it is not sometimes the left will tell
you well michael sex and gender are
different sex is not gender and they say
that and they have a lot of confidence
when they say that but it doesn't mean
anything it's not true they simply
declare it but they don't provide any
evidence for that what they seem to be
insinuating is that sex is physical and
gender is metaphysical but then you have
to probe that question further you say
okay well where is gender gender is not
in the brain it's not in the body it's
not in the genitals it's not in the
chromosomes so what is gender it's
non-physical okay would seem that you're
talking about the soul right you're
talking about the human soul
and very often at that point they'll say
no absolutely not the soul is not real
we're just talking i'm talking about the
brain okay well if you're talking about
the brain then you're saying it's
physical so now you're saying that sex
and gender are physical and yet your
your physicality can be both male
entirely male and entirely female that's
not possible that violates the law of
non-contradiction we've known that since
old uncle aristotle
well even if they go and say okay gender
is non-physical
let's say they'll say that gender is
socially constructed okay if it's
socially constructed then reconstruct it
if it's causing you this great deal of
suffering and one of them is immutable
your body your physique and then the
other one is changeable your your
socially constructed gender identity
then just reconstruct it that's pretty
easy problem solved why would you
undergo painful destructive
surgeries and hormone therapies when you
could just change the social
construction well no because it's back
in the body okay then we're back to
square one it's an incoherent ideology
that benefits absolutely no one and is
driving society crazy because a bunch of
elites can't work through their own
personal problems and because a bunch of
elites are enthralled to an
extraordinarily stupid and destructive
ideology
it's not just this woman it's not just
this lady
who's who what are the odds has two
trans and pansexual children
the the odds of having one
even according to the most generous
statistics are infinitesimally small the
odds of having two maybe
maybe there's something more going on
here either there is something in the
water and alex jones is right or
maybe there's something more going on
socially maybe there's something more
going on within the family maybe there's
something going on ideologically a
disney production manager
was also caught on this open call
claiming that we need more lgbt
lmnop representation all over the place
in disney i've had the privilege of
working with the moon girl team for the
last two years
and they've been really open to
exploring queer stories and part of i'm
on the production side uh part of uh the
work that i feel like i can put in is um
making sure that we take place in modern
day new york so making sure that that's
like an accurate reflection of new york
so i put together like a tracker of our
background characters to make sure that
we have like the full breadth of
expression and uh we got into a very
similar conversation carrie of like oh
all of our
like gender non-conforming characters
are in the background and so it's not
just a numbers game um
of how many lgbtq plus characters you
have
we got
the further
uh the more centered a story is on a
character the more nuanced you get to
get into their story and especially with
like trans characters you can't see if
someone is trans there's not one way to
look trans and so kind of the only way
to have these like canonical trans
characters canonical asexual characters
canonical bisexual characters is to give
them stories where they can like be
their whole selves
canonical
transsexual care not we don't just need
the characters we mean canonical
transsexual and canonical asexual
characters
where they can be themselves that's the
funniest part of all that's the funniest
part of all because the transgender
ideology explicitly says as that
commenter made clear at the top it
explicitly says don't be yourself
be an imaginary version of yourself
be
a fantasy
be the way that you
would prefer that yourself to be rather
than the way that you are in reality
it's the opposite of living
authentically it's the opposite of
living your true life even asexuality
man is a sexual being
sex is very important to human nature as
we all know that's why we're debating
sex so much in our politics
we need more of these characters it made
me think disney is just over disney's
just completely over i like disney i was
never a crazy disney kid i never i
didn't watch the disney channel i wasn't
gaga over the movies but i liked them in
particular i liked pinocchio i liked
the lion king i liked the movies i
watched them as a kid i liked the older
ones snow white
and those movies really were great
and i don't just want to sound like an
old fuddy-duddy man saying everything's
worse these days but it is worse if
you're now taking really important
aspects of human nature the love between
a man and a woman at the center of the
sort of of the human world at the center
of society if you take that away if you
if you deny sex and sexual reality if
you deny
the things that motivate people and
instead you superimpose political
correctness on top of it which is a
denial of reality ultimately it's a
denial of reality well then the movies
are not going to be as good and we know
that the movies aren't as good i'm not
saying disney only makes total crap
these days but the movies that disney is
making today
are worse than the movies that disney
made 30 years ago and they're worse than
the movies that disney made 60 and 70
years ago
so we've still got the old movies
if you have them on dvd or something
good for you download them now save them
because disney is over you can't
you can't
in good conscience expose your kids to
this crap not even because it's going to
completely ruin their lives although if
they're peddling transgenderism it it
won't help but just because they're
they're just not good movies they're not
going to be edifying if the stories
they're telling are contrary to human
nature and contrary to reality and these
are the lunatics who are running disney
now these people who think that the most
important thing to do in children's
programming is pedal far left sexual
ideologies before we close out disney
we've got the executive producer latoya
ravenous talking about how it's so
important in disney one thing that she
has really taken up is queering queering
that's a verb i guess everything
our leadership over there has been so
welcoming to like my like not at all
secret gay agenda and so like i i feel
like
i felt like it was i mean like maybe it
was that way in the past but i guess
like something must have happened in the
last like like they are turning it
around they're going hard and then
all that like momentum that i felt like
that
sense of i don't have to be afraid to
like
let's have these two characters kiss
let's in the background like i was just
wherever i could just basically adding
queerness to like the if you see
anything queer in the show i'm proud of
them but like i just was like no one
would stop me and no one was trying to
stop
everywhere it's everywhere at the the
senate candidate republican senate
candidate blake masters he tweeted out
the other day in response to one of
these crazy issues he said
not everything has to be gay
we're not saying we're not saying
nothing but not
not everything not every single thing
why is this even coming up
because florida passed a law
saying that kindergarten teachers
kindergarten through third grade
teachers
can't preach
transgenderism
and sex in the classroom
this should have been common sense you
shouldn't need a law for that that
should be so obvious and in response to
disney a children's entertainment
company said no that's too far
if we can't teach transgenderism to kids
if we can't queer everything if we can't
groom little kids let's call it what it
is
then we're going to fight back we're
going to fight back in florida around
the country it is unconscionable
to give your money to disney at this
point we need to figure out
an alternative
kind of like sports sports used to be
fun they used to be an escape from the
stress of everyday life now they're a
stage for virtue signaling and political
actors well nba star jonathan isaac is
not having any of it he faced heavy
criticism
because he's a normal intelligent guy
who had problems with some of the the
crazy vaccine push and disrespecting the
american flag and he's just a normal
patriot which is why
i'm very excited to announce he's
writing a book with us called why i
stand the book will be about the rise of
his basketball career his journey into
faith christianity his strength to stand
alone in the face of immense pressure
the book is available for pre-order
right now at amazon reserve your copy
today we'll be right back with a lot
more
sex is not being discussed in
kindergartens and it's a good thing that
it is
that's the line from the left that's the
line from the left in response to the
parental rights and education bill in
florida and similar legislation that's
being proposed elsewhere in the country
the same thing that they said about
critical race theory it's not happening
it's not being taught and it's very
important and good that it's being
taught so they're speaking out of both
sides of their mouth a kindergarten
teacher
a male
kindergarten teacher just went on msnbc
to
lament the fact that he is no longer
able to discuss his love life with his
five-year-old students
it really hits hard in my heart
professionally and personally both
professionally it truly makes me feel
like
i am not trusted as a professional
um i know my kindergarten standards
through and through and um nowhere in
our curriculum does it have anything
about um teaching sexual orientation or
sexual identity um so for them to to say
that that that's happening um it you
know it's kind of crazy um but
we should be able to have discussions
and and that's what we're encouraged to
do in kindergarten and then personally
because um you know my kids do have
questions they want to know who the my
partner is in pictures outside of my
classroom and i should be able to speak
to that that's what we do as educators
we build relationships with our kids and
in order to build relationships you talk
about your home life you talk about what
you do on the weekends that's building
community i it scares me
to death that i am not going to be able
to have these conversations with my
children because they're going to ask me
what i did on the weekend i don't want
to have to hide that my partner and i
went paddleboarding this weekend
i don't know about you
i do not want this creep to have a
relationship with his children which are
really my children which is really our
children with his children he says look
he he follows the exact liberal script
he says this isn't happening
we are not teaching anything about
sexuality in the classroom and also it's
terrible because i have to be able to
teach sexuality in the classroom we're
not teaching it it's not in the
curriculum but we are discussing it
the hell do you think teaching is
teaching is when a teacher discusses
something with students that's what
that's teaching
and it's very important
that when my students ask me about my
partner in the photos outside of my
classroom why are there photos of your
boyfriend outside of the classroom
why that should not be happening
well they're they're asking questions
right you're you're luring them to ask
those questions when you post photos of
your love life in the kindergarten
classroom
and now
now i won't even be able to talk about
going paddleboarding with my boyfriend
this weekend yeah you're damn right
you're not able to talk about that what
the hell is wrong with you i usually
don't get that hot under the collar i'm
a pretty chill guy
this is the creepiest thing i've heard
in months
a kindergarten teacher
begging pleading on national television
even msnbc which nobody watches but
still national television technically
pleading to be able to talk about his
date nights with his boyfriends to
five-year-olds whom he he refers to as
his children
if this man
is this confused about the appropriate
role and behavior of a kindergarten
teacher if this man is so unwilling to
follow the law
with regard to education in florida
the man should be barred from the
classroom period i'm glad he goes on tv
i'm glad that he is exposing the kind of
creepy
radicalism that we are seeing in
the classroom
this is happening all over the place
it's not
i think we can now officially throw out
the first line the
first part of the story that we hear
from the left
it's not happening critical race theory
it's not being taught it's not being
taught it's only being taught in a few
classrooms at harvard law school and
also it's really important that we teach
it in kindergarten
we can throw out that first part now
it's not just going on in florida
uh yesterday i talked about the austin
independent school district
uh in which a teacher was complaining
because the gay pride parade at the for
the fourth grade students was was not
loud enough
it was not explicit enough well we've
got some video
thanks again to i believe it was our
friends at libs at tick tock that might
have been ian miles chong i'm not i'm
not sure i want to give appropriate
credit
uh the
the pride parade that was going on at
this austin school
was
uh it was more than just waving some
rainbow flags
so you've got
you got the flags you've got this one
woman
i think it's a woman wearing a very very
short mini skirt actually it's
no it's less than a mini skirt multiple
women wearing less than a mini skirt
lots of leather
[Music]
dancing around
with little kids
with what are they eight or nine years
old some look even younger than that
with these people
like leather daddies dressed up in
skimpy little thongs with mini skirts
covering it
stiletto heels
these people
this is shot if you if you play this
clip if you if you're not watching this
if you're listening to this right now i
encourage you to go back later on once
you pull over once you you get back
tonight i encourage you to to look at
this clip to actually watch what's going
on because my description actually is
not doing justice to how radical and
creepy this is
and obviously the flags the the trans
there's a trans flag now that's pink and
blue and then there's a pride
progress flag it's like the gay flag but
with a bunch of
racial stuff in it as well
these people
not only should not be in an elementary
school these people should be in a
prison
you should not be able to put on obscene
sexually explicit dances for and with
nine-year-olds without any consequences
by the way all of this used to be
illegal
all over the country
actually one of the
uh
toughest cities for transgenderism
cross-dressing that sort of thing was
forget about the kids for a second
was actually san francisco which is now
sort of the epicenter of this sexual
radicalism
does anybody believe
does anybody believe that this is normal
or acceptable
anyone who is not a complete radical
leftist i don't care if you straight i
don't care if you're gay i don't care
even if you're confused about which sex
you are if you are in
any way if you have any tether to
reality you cannot watch that video you
cannot
listen to these radicals and say that's
normal
no of course not this is why the vast
majority of americans support the
florida bill
this is why over 60 percent of americans
support the florida bill despite
all of the
absolute misinformation coming out from
every left-wing media outlet about it
you want to talk about that
misinformation
ron perlman
he's the actor who played hellboy and
has been in some other things ron
perlman has been going on some unhinged
twitter rants in recent days
ron perlman
just
gave a rant toward florida governor ron
desantis reacting to
the don't say gay bill
good morning governor desantis
around here
um
don't say gay
don't say
as the first two words
in a sentence spoken by a political
leader of a state
in the united states of america don't
say
don't
say you nazi pig
say
first amendment
read about it
then run for office
you piece of [ __ ]
yeah read about it read about it you
gotta read you're not doing your reading
that's why you passed a bill
that i was told by the media is called
the don't say gay bill
even though i didn't read it
and i don't realize it doesn't say don't
say anything at all
he is this guy no one has ever accused
ron perlman of being the brightest belt
in the pack but this guy
is
yelling at ron desantis for something
that he's never said
he's he's yelling about a bill
because of something the bill does not
say
then he gets really hot under the collar
about it
i i don't think
that ron perlman is an outlier
yes he's a hollywood guy yes he's a
little eccentric
i think that's what most
liberals who oppose the don't say gay
bill
i think that's what they're reacting
about i think they're reacting in
basically exactly the same way as ron
perlman they are tilting at windmills
they're fighting against something
they're knocking down straw men they're
fighting against something
that is not
real pearlman just came out he sent out
another
angry
twitter video
at senator tom cotton for his
questioning of the supreme court judge
the the nominee katanji jackson
tom cotton
that can't really be your name kenneth
what is it
product
your unpaid employees pick for you
for profit
you [ __ ] white slaver
piece of [ __ ]
that line of questioning you pulled on
that incredibly beautiful woman
yesterday
your staff is probably cowering
as you read those statistics
that they under duress put together for
you unless they're a bunch of white
slavers too
which is probably the case
who else would work for you you piece of
[ __ ]
play back your line of questioning
and tell me that wasn't the most racist
thing i've seen since jefferson davis
[ __ ] you
someone clearly received his biden crack
pipe delivery before the rest of us did
i keep waiting i keep checking my
mailbox where is my biden crack pipe and
there ron pearlman got his and probably
a few other people's before that's the
only way that i can explain this except
except for this
what's his argument his argument here is
republicans
who criticize katanji jackson the most
radical supreme court nominee ever in
the history of the country
they are racist
that's all he's saying he's got colorful
language and he's saying it in kind of a
stupid way but that's the point that's
the thesis republicans
if they oppose this nominee are racist
that's what every liberal believes
pretty much
maybe that's a little unfair that's what
every
prominent liberal
says
that's what the leading democrats say
that's what the leading television
commentators say that's what the leading
blue checkmart liberals are saying
that's what they're almost all saying
republicans are opposing this woman
because she's black because they're
racist even beyond this woman
republicans are racist
that's why they do what they do is
because they hate black people
that republicans
who
who support the florida education bill
they hate free speech they're opposing
the first that's
he he sounds like a dummy because we can
hear him and we can see him
but he's not saying anything different
than any of the prominent liberals on
either of those issues how terrifying is
that we're living in a nation
half full of ron parolemans
these are the main democrat arguments
and they're bs they're bs i mean this is
the sort of thing that you're hearing
not just from
kooks on twitter you're hearing it from
the president of the united states on a
totally separate issue but with the same
degree of dishonesty joe biden is now
shifting his attention away from kovid
that's a loser for him away from
foreign policy that's a lose reform now
he's finally got to address the economy
and and he's making an argument that has
been debunked time and time again namely
that billionaires are paying a lower tax
rate than their secretaries
under my plan as i said no one making
less than four hundred thousand dollars
a year
will pay
additional single penny in taxes no one
if you don't make 400 grand you're not
going to pay a single penny in
additional federal taxes
and the wealthy incorporation will
finally begin to pay their fair share
for most americans the last few years
were very hard
stretching them to the breaking point
but billionaires and large corporations
got richer than ever
right now billionaires pay an average
rate of eight percent on their total
income eight percent that's the average
they pay
now i'm a capitalist
but uh just i want i if you can make a
billion bucks great
just pay your fair share pay a little
bit
a firefighter and a teacher
pay more than double
double the tax rate that a billionaire
pays
that's not right
that's not fair
i love the whisper thing i love when you
get the full gamut of biden's emotions
that he doesn't seem able to control so
you get the shouty joe biden come on
come on you get and then you get
you get the secret
vaguely sexual whispering joe biden it's
not fair it's not fair he says that
billionaires are paying a lower tax rate
than teachers and firefighters and then
their secretaries except it's just not
true it's not true even politifact which
is a left-wing fact-checking outlet they
refused to give a formal declaration
true or false on this because that would
disadvantage democrats in the algorithm
on which news stories are allowed to pop
up on social media but they they said on
this claim that that
billionaires pay lower tax rate than
their secretaries they said is it true
generally no generally speaking it's not
true of course not yes
the billionaires are paying the
capital gains tax rate for a lot of the
money that they're getting but first of
all that money's already been taxed at
the corporate level so let's not forget
about that and second of all it's just
not when you look at the actual numbers
you break it down in principle it's not
true and then in practice
it's not true either
joe biden
failing on the economy failing on
foreign policy failing on crime failing
on immigration failing on public health
failing on civil liberties failing on
he's below
i'm speaking in objective terms he's
doing the wrong thing on all of those
issues but also in subjective terms the
voters don't like what he's doing he's
below in the polls on all of those
issues so what does he do now well he
just signed into law a bill that will
finally
outlaw lynching
which doesn't happen it doesn't occur
ever and is already illegal it's already
very very illegal but he's going to make
it double on illegal
it's going to be double triple illegal
biden just signed the emmett till
anti-lynching law the last lynching in
america took place
40 years ago
but that was sort of a one-off the last
the last uh
spate of lynchings hasn't really
happened for what 70 years now
uh there's something uh
you know lynching was a problem
from the late 19th century up until the
early to mid 20th century
even then though it's not like we're
talking about tens of thousands of
people being killed i mean there's still
thousands of people but
it was a much
smaller problem than i think the left
would have you believe that this was
hundreds of thousands of people were
being killed and it's not true it was a
it was a problem it was a big issue
extrajudicial killings were always a
problem but it was dealt with it was
dealt with 70 years ago and it's already
against the law by definition it's
against the law it's extrajudicial and
then they beefed up legal protections
and then it went away and now joe biden
is trying to solve a problem that was
solved 70 years ago because he can't
solve any of the problems that are going
on today
and i say this as an italian american
you know the italian americans were the
victims of the largest mass lynching in
american history all right so i said
this is a
i'm speaking with all of the credibility
and authority and ethos of identity
politics that the left forces on us i'm
telling you as a as a son of rome
it's not a problem it's not a problem
and joe biden's only signing this thing
so that he can get a victory for a
problem that doesn't exist
because there are a lot of problems that
do exist and he's making all of those
worse
how did this guy become president
how
we're told he got
the most votes ever
for anyone ever in the history of voting
he's so he's the most popular president
ever and yet he's below water on
every issue his approval rating is in
the tank the only thing he's got going
for him is that while his approval
rating is in the 30s his administration
is somehow even less popular his vice
president is much less popular kamala
harris
so how'd it happen
some people suggest there were
shenanigans in the 2020 election
i i've suggested that
in fact we know that that's true we know
that in the 2020 election
there was outright illegality we know
that the way the election was conducted
in pennsylvania was not constitutional
according to the state constitution
state constitution expressly prohibits
widespread mail-in ballots
the state pushed it anyway
and so that that's just one example we
know that there were irregularities
let's call them
in a lot of states well now right here
on real clear politics
there's new peer-reviewed research that
finds evidence of 2020 voter fraud the
claim that's generally there are three
claims one is
no no shenanigans at all yes democrats
changed all the election rules in the
weeks and months before the election yes
it took a long time to count the ballots
yes there were some anomalies but no
it's the totally safest
best election ever no one has any doubts
about it if you if you doubt the results
then you're a crazy kooky conspiracy
theorist then there's the second group
which says yes
obviously the election was rigged they
changed the rules there were a lot of
problems but it wasn't enough to change
the the results of the election so biden
would have still won but yeah there were
some shenanigans then there's the third
group which says we're not so sure if
biden
actually got the most votes in the right
places to become president he is the
president now he's been sworn in he is
he's effectively the president but
maybe that election wasn't totally
kosher well this this new peer-reviewed
research from john r lott
who is the president of the crime
prevention research center and until
january of 2021 was the senior advisor
for research and statistics at the
department of justice's office of legal
policy where he dealt specifically with
issues of voter fraud
he seems to think the election was a lot
more
rife with abuse
than people are letting on he points out
the point of this is not to contest the
2020 election i think it's probably
silly to contest the 2020 election it's
uh it's over joe biden is the president
maybe he won fair and square maybe he
totally cheated maybe it was a stolen
election he is the president though
there's no there have been stolen
elections in american history that's how
that's how lyndon johnson became a
senator and then became the president
through a stolen election so that
happened but the reason that it's
important i know a lot of republicans
just want to move on this they don't
raise any questions about the
irregularities in 2020 don't even raise
the prospect of cheating what's very
important not because of 2020 that's
over we're in it we're in it we're under
the biden administration
it's because of 2024 it's because if we
do not
have confidence in our elections then
the republic's going to crumble
democrats don't have confidence in it
republicans don't have confidence in it
there's evidence of a lot of rigging
going on
and so we have to keep talking about
that because of this basic political
issue it's why we keep talking about
transgenderism actually in a certain way
because if we can't
agree on the definition of man and woman
it doesn't matter what our tax debates
are going to be it doesn't matter even
what our debates over crime or
immigration are going to be we can't
speak to each other if we can't speak to
each other we can't have self-government
if we don't have
faith in our most basic systems of
politics and government then all those
second order political debates are not
going to matter the country is in a very
tough spot
we need to get back to basics can we
trust our votes can we trust our system
of election and perhaps more importantly
than anything
do we even know what a man and a woman
is anymore i'm michael knowles this is
the michael nola show see you tomorrow
[Music]
michael knowles show is produced by ben
davies executive producer jeremy boring
supervising producer mathis glover
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer danny d'amico
associate producer justine turley audio
mixer mike coromina and hair and makeup
by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022. on
the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show